there's domingo herman you can see it's
been a while for him
going back to 2019 he was 18 and four it
was a breakout year for him
so two down here in the top of the first
and bow bishop
the o2 shot inside the right field line
it'll bounce off the wall and back out
into fair territory frazier's got it but
can't get it back in
before beau bechet without his batting
helmet glides into second with a two-out
double
here's tayoska hernandez crowd looking
for a strikeout
and they get it slider struck him out
great first inning
for harman no runs one hit one left zork
has a two-and-one record so far against
the yankees in his young career
aaron judge the batter first pitch
swinging and a liner to second
caught by a leaping simeon for out
number two
boy so far we have seen some nice plays
from simeon at second base he really
looks comfortable at sac
he is shaded up the middle and times his
leap perfectly as he spears that one
to the top of the second inning and
here's vladimir
guerrero on one is
drilled to right field and deep and gone
guerrero with an opposite field home run
his first
of the season and the blue jays have
taken an early one to nothing lead
and in the beauty of this swing the home
run goes to right field
i think that's the one thing that vlady
has really focused on all spring long
hitting the ball
up the middle to the opposite field he's
staying on pitches
and he's really swinging the bat well
it's a runner with second you can see
randall has liked hitting against the
yankees just like gurion
he's got an eight-game hit streak
against new york one-two again
and a fastball club to left well hit can
he keep it fair
and yes he can randall grinchuk hits a
bullet down the left field line for a
two run homer
and it is three to nothing blue jays
what a terrific reward for a good at
back for randall grichik he battled off
a couple of tough pitches shortened up
his stroke
and that's validation once again you
don't have to have a big swing to hit
the ball out of the ballpark
well one away and here is jay bruce
jay bruce rips one to right field and it
is a base hit
jay bruce will love that so he picks up
his second yankee hit
then frazier is the batter now and he
got him
a slider took a little bit more off now
one away here is brett
gardner that one is punched the other
way gonna be a difficult play it's gonna
be a base hit
the ground ball forced bouchette to move
a little toward third
here is lemayo
and there's a base hit to right field
the gardner stops at second i mean
lemay you could do that i think with his
eyes closed
inside swing and spray the ball to right
field and now here's aaron judge coming
up with a couple of men
on your one on the way to judge and a
swing and a ground ball to second simeon
the flip besheck
spins and fires and they turn the double
play
oh what a nifty play by beau buchette at
the bag at second
and a new yankee pitcher domingo
jorman's day is done
after three and the yankees will turn to
michael king two down now for
kavanaugh biggio runners going and the
pitch
bounced to first i think we got
catcher's interference
biggio looked back right away towards
the plate
and it appears that it has been called
and that'll be an
error charge to sanchez no time at bad
for bisho and there's another aspect of
catching
reach that mid out a little bit too far
and clip bizio's bad
and that'll keep the inning alive he
reaches for the ball
and biggio's bat hit the catcher's mitt
and sanchez knew it right away
so did to jordan baker the home plate
empire and the bases are loaded
with two outs and beau bashette very
dangerous batter in the box
a little chopper to first bruce fields
steps on the bag ends the inning so came
pitched out of trouble
pete walker was thrilled with the
progress that he has seen from trent
thornton
and he is working his way back toward
being another starting pitching
option let off by clint frazier
popped up run down but not run down
thought he could get there and going to
second is frazier with a hustle double
tell you what that little spotted area
of grass there in short right field has
been
worn out in this first series and again
clint fraser
hustling out of the box look at that not
watching the end result
and just making this a double now it's
important for the yankees to trail by
three runs
to move the runner high fly ball
left center grichik makes the play
tagging is frasier
here's the throw he's in there as he
advances
now if gardner hits a ground ball
anywhere but third frazier will score
that's going to get a running ground
ball to simeon
and the yankees now are trailing by two
it's three to one an rbi for gardner
and here is randall greeck
grichik lost one to right field clint
frazier is there
and makes the play as he stumbles to his
knees for the first down
one away torres here's the 2-2
swung on and line to left field deep
down the line and that ball is going to
be off
the base of the left field wall taurus
heads towards second
there with a double pretty much the same
pitch that he missed earlier in the
count
fouled off he got it again and see that
back shoulder underneath the ball a
little
bit and as we thought with a left-handed
battery do up in jay bruce that'll be
all for thor
ryan burrucky coming in one-two pitch
on the way and a swing and a ball up the
middle one hopper speared by machete
spins and fires to first to get him
bruce retired
torres will come to third on the play
but what a nice play by boba shad
that ball took a wicked hop up the
middle bow is shaded up the middle and
bruce hits a one hopper it takes a
funny hop but he stays with it throws
him out at first
nice play by buchet to take a hit away
from jay bruce
oh two way and here is bo bashed
rounded to short quite a performance
by michael king four shutout innings out
of the bullpen at the end of six and a
half and now out of the bullpen at the
bottom of the seventh comes david phelps
george
swing and a miss on a good ball away and
phelps looking very sharp as he strikes
out her shell at two down
red gardener the batter blue jays would
love nothing more than for phelps to
finish it off right here
2-2 and he will swinging a miss and a
fastball up above the belt as he gets
gardner
so here is alejandro kirk it's the 0-1
swung on a little bloop in the infield
caught by lemayo
and king pitches six utterly
brilliant innings and now meriwether's
gotten the first two batters in the nine
gary sanchez up for the yankees one
two pitch on the way stays with a
fastball
swung on and missed and meriwether has
done it again
the blue jays beat the yankees three to
one and they take
two out of three in the bronx